[Applause]
none of this was supposed to happen
joe biden assuming office as the 46th
president of the united states
instead the military should have stepped
in to keep trump in power
at least if you are one of the many
followers of kyunan
when that reality failed to materialize
the kyunong community reacted with
disappointment
confusion and anger some refused to
believe what they were seeing
right after biden was inaugurated you
saw a lot of
a lot of anger a lot of feelings of
betrayal a lot of people who
sort of exclaimed i you know i'm i'm
done with this i'm never gonna believe
in it again
kudon supporters are really faced with
an existential dilemma
either their belief system was correct
and this is leading to some sort of
logical conclusion
or they have to face despair q anon
followers tried to somehow reconcile the
inauguration
with the same web of conspiracy theories
that said it wouldn't happen
they simply adapted the narrative of
their alternative reality
one that more people believe in than you
might think
an npr ipsos poll found that 17 of
americans
and 23 percent of republicans believe
that a group of satan worshipping elites
who run a child sex ring are trying to
control our politics and media
a key tenant of the q anon movement
and with congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene from georgia
support for the conspiracy theory has
even reached the highest levels of u.s
politics
in this video we will take a closer look
at where it all came from
and what comes next for q anon since
there is no clear cut definition of q
anon
we ask the experts people who have been
studying the movement for years
q anon is a cultish conspiracy theory
that claims that a military intelligence
team
is using the board kun to leak
classified information about an upcoming
purge of the deep state and they do this
using codes and riddles and pictures
that are meant to be
interpreted by followers and it's been
going on since
uh end of october 2017. so it all
started in october 2017
when a cryptic text appeared on the
online discussion board
4chan notorious for extremist content
one of the early statements hillary
clinton will soon be arrested
the obscure message by an anonymous
self-proclaimed
cue clearance patriot would hardly have
attracted attention
but 4chan moderators and youtubers began
to knit a complete legend around this
and the posts that followed they
speculated that the author must have
access to the country's nuclear secrets
the key anonymous was born hue
clearance is an actual uh us department
of energy term it's
uh it's the classification given to
people who work with
nuclear weapons it has nothing at all to
do with military intelligence
but it sounds cool so i think whoever
makes the posts picked it up because hey
it's it
sounds cool it sounds mysterious it's an
easily
brandable thing that we can run with
it's impossible to verify who wrote the
first text
or whether the following posts assigned
to q anon were even by the same person
or group
all publications on 4chan are anonymous
the main q anon posts later migrated
from 4chan to other boards like 8chan
now called 8con so what are the key
messages of queue
queues texts so-called cue drops are
often cryptic or completely
incomprehensible
they mostly consist of scraps of
sentences or questions
but q anon followers have woven them all
into an overarching myth
of a dark secret elite that is said to
control the world
by means of the deep state this has
elements of age-old anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
and now they're underpinning the q anon
ideology
but the movement has also broadened to
embrace many common elements of other
conspiracy theories
for q a non-believers the central figure
in fighting this secret elite
and the alleged deep state is donald
trump
what matters is that trump
and q they are there to fight against
something that's not just
you know it's not just bureaucratic it's
not just this
you know poorer version of government
it's the idea that what they're fighting
against
is a genuine evil and they're
responsible for
making so many things in the world
absolutely terrible you know it ties
into things like the idea that
kovid's been manufactured you know that
people are being kept in
kept in poverty because of the the
actions of the this shadowy deep state
trump's rhetoric created an ideal
breeding ground for conspiracy theory
unelected deep state operatives who defy
the voters
to push their own secret agendas
are truly a threat to democracy itself
and as long as trump was in office the
kyonon community
could interpret every step he took as
part of his alleged plan to fight the
deep state
the last presidential election was a
major setback
but trump's refusal to accept his defeat
gave the movement a last push
until joe biden peacefully assumed
office as us president
so what's next for q anon will it all
come to an end now
since predictions of trump staying in
power to finish his mission turned out
to be wrong
some of these supporters who are really
disappointed now
and they feel betrayed some of them are
reflecting
did i really spoil my last three and a
half years believing in this
ideology and nothing of this is true and
on the other hand of course there's a
group as
it's always conspiracy ideologies who
say
no no it's still the plan it's all very
fine
and at the moment this is as i said
interesting to watch but of course
there's always a danger that these
people
stop talking at one point and then think
they have to act and if they think they
have to act they could also act
violently as we know
and this is a big fear for the next
months to watch
many q anon supporters have already
proven that they are prepared to use
violence
when a mob of furious trump supporters
stormed the capital in washington dc on
january 6
lots of cue flags and shirts could be
seen in the crowd
[Music]
prominent figures who took part like
jake anjali
the man wearing horns and of her hat
were part of the q anon world
ashley elizabeth babbitt the 35 year old
woman who was fatally shot by capitol
police
was also a follower of kyonon and had
tweeted the previous day
the storm is here the storming of the
capital
did not lead to the reversal of the
election result that q anon followers
were hoping for
but experts say that's unlikely to spell
the end
of the movement i think it's probably
too soon to tell exactly
what will happen but i can tell you that
the people who believe in this are going
to continue to believe it
you know the the sort of classic
conspiracy theories are always about
a sort of vast string pulling group
doing terrible things to you where cue
was different is that it gave you a way
to fight back
and that way still exists of making
videos making memes
you know decoding the signs and the
communications that are done in public
that's not gonna change you know some of
the ideas that we can
you know send out a tweet and destroy
the deep state that's
that is going to change and i don't know
exactly where that'll land but the basic
beliefs are still going to be the same
of course the movement will have to
adapt with joe biden in the white house
the role of trump in the queue universe
is at stake
trump might not law might no longer be
the center of the spectacle
he might not be the face they see on
television people have coped in this
uh in several ways obviously they've uh
the idea that uh biden is in on this
either in a way where he's turning
himself in in the long run
or in a way where he is actually just a
kind of um
implanted agent for this broader storm
this movement
that they they see happening so there's
going to be a lot of
mental adaptations i think to the
situation as it stands
and while trump's part in the narrative
will have to be twisted
other elements of the story will
continue in 2021
such as covet 19. the pandemic was this
huge
recruiting opportunity for q anon
promoters you know they saw this
there's this huge massive people dealing
with this enormous event and a lot of
people were
isolated they were bored they were at
home they weren't working
and you go down rabbit holes and you
start looking you start looking for
reasons
why this is going on and if q is
providing them in the form of
you know the deep state in china did
this to prop up joe biden
it's as good an explanation as anything
while some followers have expressed a
lot of anger and will turn their back on
q anon now
the movement is likely to attract others
in times of uncertainty
a worst case would be further
radicalization leading to violence
donald trump said in his farewell
address the best
is yet to come a sentence that might be
further inspiration to keep the movement
[Music]
alive